I'm just it's been such a long time
coming and I'm excited for the fans to
see it I feel like they've been waiting
for a long time we've been working on it
for so long that it's finally nice to
just let it be we all read books and we
all have an idea of what they're going
to be like and we're playing them on
your head and we're casting them and
everything so it's just exciting to be
able to be part of the thing that you
know we have created our best version of
what they want you know and that's just
a really cool thing and I just I'm just
so excited for them to see it I would
say thank you because you know there's
such an important part of this and I'm
so happy that you know it's not just
sort of big premieres but movie stars
the Premier Zhou for the fans I mean and
they get to see it before anyone and I
think that's a really good way of
honoring and saying thank you hey
awesome it's awesome you know if you
touch people that way it's just it's
yeah it's it's pretty special and I'm
very very nothing I have no words it was
just incredible the acting the chemistry
it really they really brought the book
to life they were perfect together I've
been thinking about it for months and
months and months and then now that I
kind of feel like this is it i think the
way they portray the relationship
between the gentleman
was just perfect I think it just kind of
brings you closer to two significant
other so she dragged me into it and I
really liked it so I suggested for sure
you